hello everyone i'm magnus carlson from
norway
chess world champion since 2013.
i'm going to break down a couple of
games from the
queen's gambit series so please enjoy
the one that was most aesthetically
pleasing for me
even though in a way it was very very
simple
it was the one from the kentucky state
championship from
from 1963
basically here he's one move away from a
draw
which considering everything that
happened
would be an enormous achievement for for
him
uh and he carelessly decides to
to to take her last pawn and indeed what
could be
more natural right she has a rook and
a knight and a king against the rook and
three pawns
and experienced chess players they will
know
that against good defense you cannot win
with a rook and a knight against just a
rook
even if he loses all his pawns
he should be able to make a draw after
he's grabbed that last pawn
however he's been careless
he's overlooked the fact that these
pawns they're all in the way
and they're taking away squares from
from his rook
and simply by attacking
the rook with the with the king as she
does
uh not once but but twice
she attacks the the rook the rook um
the rook has to move one square away and
then she attacks it with
with uh with the king again and at this
point
the rook has so many squares
it has practically a full board to
choose from
but wherever the rock goes it's either
going to be forked
by the knight or captured by the king
or the rook or or the knight then he
with a smile she realizes or that his
rooks is trapped
and then for some reason he doesn't
realize it as well
he moves the rook away and uh he gets
forked and he
um and he loses a really pretty
uh segment there it's a game segment
that i'd never seen before
and it's a theme that you so rarely see
and to me was so beautiful in
its uh simplicity and
it shows the kind of imagination that
she had
at a very early age um
that this one i i just found
to be really really lovely
i hope you guys enjoyed these little
bits from beth
harmon's games and uh go out and play
have fun